seguimos hablando de economía aquí en
directo américa ya está conmigo en el
estudio nuevamente jorge hurtado jorge
qué bueno tenerlo de nuevo aquí en el
estudio vamos a hablar ahora del aumento
del precio del petróleo a nivel mundial
así es raúl y es que el petróleo tocó su
máximo en siete años por la preocupación
de posibles interrupciones del
suministro este incremento sea luego de
que el grupo desde yemen atacará los
emiratos árabes unidos- se sumará una
nueva tensión geopolítica los futuros
del grupo del crudo frame subieron 44
centavos para cotizar en 86 92 dólares
el barril pero antes tocó un máximo de
87 dólares su nivel más alto desde el 30
de octubre de 2014 por su parte los
futuros del crudo a west texas de eeuu
subieron 81 centavos a 1 por ciento con
respecto al cierre del viernes para
ubicarse hasta los 84 62 dólares por
barril los rebeldes hutíes lanzaron ayer
un ataque con drones y misiles a
emiratos árabes unidos- que provocaron
explosiones en camiones de combustible
mataron a tres personas asimismo
advirtieron de más ataques para varios
analistas es poco hablé que el ajustado
equilibrio entre la oferta y la demanda
se reduzca ya que algunos productores de
la organización de países exportadores
de petróleo están luchando para bombear
a su capacidad permitida jorge y ayer
inició el foro económico mundial en
davos le pregunto que han dicho los
principales líderes mundiales bueno hace
unos minutos habló el primer ministro
israelí naftalí bennett dijo que su país
se ha convertido en una potencia en
materia de ciberseguridad a medida que
el mundo avance hacia el trabajo remoto
por la pandemia escuchamos
a medida que el mundo se vuelve más
dependiente del trabajo remoto significa
que también vamos a ser más vulnerables
a los ciberataques for tax a watchmen
wind y lo que significa que necesitamos
el mejor ciberdefensa israel ha
invertido masivamente en tecnología sea
de ciberdefensa tecla badges and i'
bolígrafo y creo que la mitad o casi la
mitad de las inversiones mundiales en
empresas cibernéticas en los últimos
años han sido en israel así que israel
se ha convertido en una potencia en
ciberseguridad
a favor de fans pasamos jorge ahora
hablar del transporte marítimo y los
problemas en la cadena de suministros
global así es y es que varios analistas
raúl ya apuntan a que los altos precios
del transporte marítimo van a continuar
al menos hasta mediados de este año lo
que supone otro año de beneficios para
los transportistas de carga mundial en
2021 fue un año de incremento en las
tarifas de transporte marítimo un
contenedor de 40 pies con destino a eeuu
desde asia supera los 20 mil dólares el
año pasado incluidos los recargos y las
primas cuando valía menos de 2 mil
dólares hace unos años y recientemente
rondaba a los 14 mil dólares según
bloomberg la congestión de los puertos
hacen que las tarifas a largo plazo
entre los transportistas y los
cargadores sea un 200% más altas que
hace un año los transportistas de carga
marítima obtuvieron beneficios estimados
raúl de 150 mil millones de dólares en
2021 esto es un aumento de 9 veces a lo
que venían recibiendo varios economistas
advirtieron que los altos precios de
transporte avivan la inflación y frenan
la recuperación económica mientras estos
aumentos se están reconvirtiendo ya en
fenómenos a largo plazo para economía
como eeuu y algunos países europeos
señor ya dijo jorge la red de 5g usted
piensa en catástrofe no necesariamente
pero las aerolíneas eeuu sí porque a ti
te nos de efectos catastróficos por la
llegada de esta red 5g le pregunta
entonces el por qué usted tiene la
respuesta bueno así es a un día de que
esta tecnología se active en eeuu prensa
y las principales aerolíneas pidieron al
gobierno que bloquee la transmisión de
señales 5g en un radio de 3,2 kilómetros
alrededor de las pistas de aterrizaje de
los aeropuertos las aerolíneas están
preocupadas de que las nuevas señales 5g
puedan generar interferencias en los
radio altímetros de los aviones estos
aparatos son los que miden la distancia
entre la aeronave y el suelo así como
los sistemas de datos de ayuda a los
aviones para aterrizar este debate que
lleva ya varias semanas hizo katie
verisón accedieron a retrasar dos
semanas el lanzamiento de las nuevas
bandas de frecuencias 5g hasta este
miércoles 19 de enero haití en tibet
reason ganaron casi todo el espectro de
la banda ce en una subasta de 80.000
millones de dólares el año pasado la
administración federal de aviación dijo
que tiene una lista de 50 aeropuertos
que tendrán zonas acción cuando las
compañías activen este nuevo servicio
pero las aerolíneas afirman que la lista
es insuficiente american airlines delta
united software airlines y otras
empresas dijeron a la casablanca que a
menos que los principales centros estén
autorizados para volar sus pasajeros se
van a quedar en tierra vamos a ver
entonces qué va a pasar jorge con esta
tecnología 5g y las aerolíneas de eeuu
le pregunta ahora por los indicadores
vamos con hacia los mercados bursátiles
asiáticos cerraron negativos por los
rendimientos del tesoro estadounidense
por los riesgos de una subida del tipo
de interés de la reserva federal y en
europa las acciones europeas cayeron el
martes con los valores tecnológicos
presionados también por la subida de los
rendimientos de los bonos del tesoro de
eeuu jorge gracias entonces por toda la
información económica nos vemos mañana
con más economía que en directo américa
vamos ahora directos a parís
[Música]